Caption: hello everyone my name is sam price and
Caption: i'm currently a software architect with
Caption: family zone cyber
Caption: over safety
Caption: last probably six or seven years or so
Caption: i've had the opportunity to
Caption: be involved with systems that have
Caption: needed to scale um quite often scale
Caption: quite considerable amounts and
Caption: through those experiences there have
Caption: been lessons learned observations and
Caption: changes to daily routines
Caption: and it's the ladder bit that i'd like to
Caption: talk a little bit about today so things
Caption: how i've changed my daily routine to
Caption: keep performance in mind
Caption: okay
Caption: now before we get into it i just wanted
Caption: to say thank you to all of our amazing
Caption: sponsors um dignity perth
Caption: as an attendee has always been my my
Caption: favorite con conference and it wouldn't
Caption: be possible without all of the sponsors
Caption: so thank you very much for supporting
Caption: local local perth talent
Caption: why practical performance
Caption: well i'm going to suggest a few reasons
Caption: that um the companies that i've worked
Caption: for
Caption: value but then later suggest one of my
Caption: own
Caption: our customers without customers we we
Caption: can't make money typically
Caption: and so we we need our customers to have
Caption: compelling experiences
Caption: now jacob nielsen was actually a very
Caption: well regarded usability expert
Caption: and a lot of the ux
Caption: design
Caption: principles these days are actually based
Caption: on on his foundation
Caption: foundational research
Caption: if you do a quick google search you'll
Caption: find many many statistics on
Caption: what happens when sites are unresponsive
Caption: or apps take a long time to to load
Caption: screens
Caption: and i'm sure we've all seen these kinds
Caption: of things before so i've just selected a
Caption: few random
Caption: stats
Caption: both from google in the hope that you
Caption: trust it there they're real and true
Caption: why else
Caption: low operating costs
Caption: uh
Caption: these days uh infrastructure hosting is
Caption: a major expense for a lot of a lot of
Caption: companies and particularly in the the
Caption: new world or newish world of cloud it's
Caption: very easy to inadvertently dial up uh
Caption: how much you're spending and so i'm
Caption: hoping that through good
Caption: good performance practices we can keep
Caption: our costs a little bit lower and
Caption: i think we all may have experienced this
Caption: this kind of thing before where the
Caption: easiest thing to do is to vertically
Caption: scale um but it's not not effectively
Caption: the most cost effective
Caption: and so if we we have good performance
Caption: practices quite often our software will
Caption: end up performing too
Caption: which typically keeps our costs low
Caption: and the final reason is that
Caption: i've observed that a lot of software
Caption: engineers don't necessarily include
Caption: practical
Caption: performance practices in their daily
Caption: routine
Caption: now i don't necessarily blame them
Caption: i think this is sort of the
Caption: classic quote premature optimization is
Caption: the root of all evil
Caption: i think
Caption: most of us have heard that and it does
Caption: discourage us a little bit from thinking
Caption: about performance
Caption: and
Caption: so
Caption: now sir tony horror actually uh expands
Caption: on his often misquoted quote
Caption: and explains that really we shouldn't
Caption: think about
Caption: micro optimizations 97 of the time but
Caption: instead spend that 97 percent of time uh
Caption: with good software design so
Caption: what algorithms and data structures
Caption: we're going to use how we'll design apis
Caption: and things like that
Caption: performance principles
Caption: i personally use when i when i look at
Caption: my day-to-day work but then also
Caption: when designing solutions
Caption: and i'll present two principles that i
Caption: use
Caption: so the first one is craftsmanship
Caption: which is really well designed software
Caption: systems using modern technologies and
Caption: processors will outperform systems built
Caption: in an ad hoc manner without good process
Caption: much like how craft beer out-tastes
Caption: factory beer
Caption: so what does it mean to be to
Caption: practice craftsmanship
Caption: so
Caption: firstly we need to understand our
Caption: customers and our users how they're
Caption: using our software
Caption: and what they need we need to need to
Caption: understand our programming languages
Caption: we need to understand what what third
Caption: party i guess technologies that our
Caption: software solutions integrate with so
Caption: databases caches queues various other
Caption: bits and pieces
Caption: um how is our software being run
Caption: are we running it are we using linux as
Caption: an os or is it an ec2 maybe we're using
Caption: kubernetes for orchestration
Caption: and then sort of the glue that holds all
Caption: of this together is
Caption: good old computer science theory so
Caption: from human computer interaction for our
Caption: users all the way through to data
Caption: structures and algorithms
Caption: and so
Caption: to exhibit craftsmanship it'd be
Caption: wonderful to be an expert in all of
Caption: these things but the reality is that's
Caption: that's not going to be possible and so
Caption: we'll each have
Caption: various skill depths
Caption: but really i think what we what we kind
Caption: of need to do is to uh as software
Caption: engineers spend a little bit of time to
Caption: to understand
Caption: our tools so that we can hopefully write
Caption: performance solutions that are good for
Caption: our businesses and customers and so how
Caption: might we do this we're all busy we've
Caption: all got different routines so i'd
Caption: suggest that actually what we want to do
Caption: is narrow our scope so don't try and
Caption: understand every aspect of a database
Caption: instead just focus on on one little
Caption: thing
Caption: similarly factor in time for planning
Caption: and learning so
Caption: some of us might be practicing agile
Caption: and so when we do estimation it's nice
Caption: to bump that up a little bit if we if we
Caption: want to go and spend time to deliver
Caption: something quality
Caption: and obviously anything that we've
Caption: learned we wish to apply during the
Caption: implementation phase
Caption: now here's an example of
Caption: where
Caption: i guess a team that i've worked with
Caption: where we had a lapse in craftsmanship
Caption: there were two services that
Caption: communicated to each other
Caption: both
Caption: http
Caption: one service used an http library called
Caption: apache http components and
Caption: we brought that in in its default
Caption: configuration without reading the manual
Caption: and the manual very clearly states
Caption: no more than two concurrent connections
Caption: per given route so that means i cannot
Caption: have more than two threads making
Caption: requests to a single uri on a single
Caption: host
Caption: which is actually very limiting and that
Caption: proved to be the case for us and sadly
Caption: this happened twice
Caption: the other principle that i wanted to
Caption: introduce is less is more i think a lot
Caption: of us would have heard of that before
Caption: but um the idea here is that a system
Caption: that does less is more for performance
Caption: than a system that does more and
Caption: certainly in the sort of ultra high
Caption: performance um
Caption: sort of category
Caption: really high performing systems like have
Caption: almost no features they do one thing and
Caption: they do it very well
Caption: now what are some examples of less is
Caption: more i could probably write a list of
Caption: about 50 things here but i'll keep it
Caption: fairly limited
Caption: one of my favorites is
Caption: complexity so kiss holds holds true and
Caption: at all levels as well so from the the
Caption: level of actually writing code
Caption: if you're using a compiled language
Caption: for example
Caption: the compiler will often optimize your
Caption: code and the compiler does a better job
Caption: of optimizing simple code than it does
Caption: complex code
Caption: all the way up to maybe a service level
Caption: if you've got a fairly simple service
Caption: maybe it's a microservice but it has
Caption: some deficiency it's much easier to
Caption: replace that service than a horribly
Caption: complex monolith
Caption: and so
Caption: i'm not advocating either way by the way
Caption: for
Caption: mono said minor services so
Caption: sorry
Caption: monoliths or micro services
Caption: um but yeah this list goes on and on but
Caption: i won't i won't go through all of these
Caption: things
Caption: and here's a classic
Caption: table from the greater internet some of
Caption: us may have seen this before
Caption: the thing that i like about this table
Caption: is enables me to understand what happens
Caption: when my software is run through the eyes
Caption: of the computer a little bit and how
Caption: long various things take
Caption: but to make it a little bit more clear i
Caption: thought it might be fun if we pretended
Caption: that
Caption: we're in perth and
Caption: for us to go to the level one cache is
Caption: just one simple step
Caption: but then for us to actually send two
Caption: kilobytes over a gigabit network well
Caption: that's that's like us going all the way
Caption: to free mountain back
Caption: well
Caption: what about if we wanted to read a meg
Caption: from memory um that's like us going to
Caption: dancer and back it's quite a while like
Caption: sorry us going just in amsterdam quite a
Caption: while and then finally a single packet
Caption: from perth to california and back to
Caption: perth again halfway to the moon
Caption: so if we think about these things when
Caption: writing software
Caption: it
Caption: puts things into perspective a little
Caption: bit
Caption: so this is a an example where we
Caption: leveraged less is more um
Caption: so the context here is that we had a
Caption: native library that filtered network
Caption: traffic now i've ported that code and
Caption: simplified it to java
Caption: and this library it one runs on our
Caption: wi-fi routers but we we wanted to reuse
Caption: that at the end of our vpn
Caption: and so all of a sudden the environment
Caption: has changed we went from 20 uh
Caption: queries per second really to about 2 000
Caption: queries per second
Caption: and our poor little filter client
Caption: library did not like it so this is the
Caption: code beforehand and
Caption: after looking at the code we made a
Caption: simple change
Caption: did anybody see it
Caption: so anyway we changed a tree map to a
Caption: hashmap
Caption: so why would replacing treemap with
Caption: hashmap make a difference
Caption: well
Caption: obviously the synchronized block itself
Caption: is a bit of an issue and it's mutually
Caption: exclusive and blocks all but one thread
Caption: and that one thread spends obviously too
Caption: long from getting a decision from the
Caption: cache
Caption: but but why still why does it take so
Caption: long to get a decision from the cache
Caption: and to be fair it doesn't actually take
Caption: that long but um the difference here is
Caption: that tree map is based on a red black
Caption: tree and hash map is based on a hash
Caption: table
Caption: now i realize at this point not everyone
Caption: in this room has probably
Caption: studied computer science and and knows
Caption: about big o notation so that search
Caption: column is big o notation
Caption: and it says that
Caption: a red black tree runs in log in time and
Caption: a hash table runs in constant time but
Caption: what does that actually mean
Caption: so the the next two columns are if i
Caption: have a cache of size 100 and a cache of
Caption: size 100 000 how long does it take me to
Caption: look up my item
Caption: well if we're using the tree map
Caption: i may need to look at six elements
Caption: before i find the one that i'm looking
Caption: for
Caption: if there are 100 elements in the cache
Caption: but if that's 100 000 then i'm going to
Caption: need to examine
Caption: uh 16 elements but our good old hash
Caption: table i only i can find the element that
Caption: i'm looking for immediately regardless
Caption: of the size of the cache
Caption: all right so principles are done but
Caption: what are some of the performance issues
Caption: that i've observed over the years and
Caption: this sort of hopefully adds some
Caption: credibility to this talk
Caption: software engineers that is a bit of a
Caption: joke
Caption: but they are the they are the people
Caption: that write the code
Caption: all right databases this happens all the
Caption: time
Caption: indexes um they're either missing or
Caption: misconfigured they've got the wrong
Caption: wrong columns or the wrong column order
Caption: now i think there could be multiple
Caption: reasons for this um
Caption: like the worst being negligence but
Caption: quite often i think that it's more of a
Caption: maintenance issue where we change the
Caption: code at the application layer but then
Caption: we forget to actually go back to the db
Caption: and update the indices to match
Caption: similarly we have each team has
Caption: individuals of different levels of
Caption: experience so
Caption: less experienced people may not know
Caption: about
Caption: indices and they also may not know about
Caption: things like database query plans
Caption: and then finally a little bit less
Caption: column but i've seen a fair bit of
Caption: database misused so because we have a
Caption: relational beat db we may as well use it
Caption: as a document db
Caption: or maybe we just need somewhere to
Caption: aggregate data so let's just use the
Caption: relational db
Caption: instead of using say a stream processing
Caption: engine so there's a lot
Caption: quite a few examples there
Caption: and probably my favorite of all is
Caption: traditional orms
Caption: so object relation mappings
Caption: this enables us to write software
Caption: without actually having to write
Caption: database queries we just
Caption: use higher level constructs and
Caption: the orm will take care of sql generation
Caption: now the primary issue with rrms that
Caption: i've observed is that the db interaction
Caption: is opaque so we we don't see
Caption: uh what sql gets generated we don't know
Caption: if it's sufficient and we don't know how
Caption: many how many times uh statements are
Caption: being created and run
Caption: and there's a very common problem called
Caption: the m plus one problem that i won't i
Caption: won't detail here but it's it's easy to
Caption: solve but it's just something to be
Caption: aware of
Caption: and then the final
Caption: performance pane with rms is select star
Caption: so whenever we use an rm it always
Caption: brings back every column of every table
Caption: even though we mainly care about three
Caption: fields and if we
Caption: roll this all the way back and think
Caption: about our users
Caption: a good user interface it only shows the
Caption: information that's relevant and nothing
Caption: more so
Caption: we should we should
Caption: treat the db the same way really
Caption: the final common performance issue that
Caption: i've observed is network ignorance
Caption: and this kind of goes back to the the
Caption: whole lessons more thing and unders
Caption: putting ourselves in the place of a
Caption: computer and think about the different
Caption: latencies involved
Caption: the network isn't particularly quick so
Caption: we should try and avoid it but yet
Caption: too often we see many network calls when
Caption: only one is required
Caption: and here is a very like here's an
Caption: example
Caption: very simple and this is in javascript
Caption: we want to
Caption: all we want to do is find all the
Caption: devices that um are in a family
Caption: and so we load all the family members
Caption: and then we iterate through them and
Caption: then we load the devices for each family
Caption: member
Caption: this is very slow um
Caption: it's not a great way to do it so i'd
Caption: encourage us to think about
Caption: having as few network calls as possible
Caption: um and ideally a single call that can do
Caption: everything that we want and actually you
Caption: know this is why graphql for example is
Caption: very popular
Caption: uh the other one is large payloads so
Caption: quite often um again if we're using an
Caption: orm we might get everything back if
Caption: we've got a restful
Caption: restful web service we might get
Caption: everything back
Caption: and particularly if we're sharing report
Caption: data or tabular data we might just do
Caption: the simple thing which is bring
Caption: everything back
Caption: so this is large payloads are more
Caption: tolerable
Caption: on fast networks with few hops but as
Caption: soon as the internet's involved and
Caption: traversing the public internet uh large
Caption: payloads become very slow
Caption: a reason for this is the tcp windows so
Caption: most http is based on top of tcp
Caption: and it and
Caption: tcp will only send a certain number of
Caption: bytes to the client before waiting for
Caption: the client to acknowledge them
Caption: and then after it gets the
Caption: acknowledgement it will then send the
Caption: next chunk of bytes and this so each one
Caption: of those is effectively a round trip and
Caption: it can add up if you've got a very large
Caption: payload
Caption: all right no talk on performance would
Caption: be uh
Caption: it were like worthwhile without a war
Caption: story so this is a reasonably recent one
Caption: so last year family zone experienced a
Caption: period of rapid growth so these are
Caption: unique um unique visitors
Caption: and so we went from about 15 000 in
Caption: march 2020
Caption: all the way through to almost um one and
Caption: a half million by the end of the year
Caption: and
Caption: this is a wonderful way for teasing out
Caption: performance bottlenecks in your system
Caption: so
Caption: one one of those bottlenecks we have a
Caption: classroom product and so and
Caption: inadvertently this was also one of the
Caption: reasons why we had we grew so much is
Caption: that covert struck and our product
Caption: teachers could do remote learning so the
Caption: teacher could be at home the students
Caption: could be at home and the teacher could
Caption: create classes
Caption: and interact with their students so what
Caption: this screenshot is showing is the
Caption: teacher's view of the world and each
Caption: tile is a student's desktop so the
Caption: teacher can keep track of what their
Caption: students are doing and make sure that
Caption: they're all doing mathematics and that
Caption: little johnny isn't off on youtube
Caption: so
Caption: an approximation of part of the
Caption: architecture is this so we have the
Caption: teachers browsers on the bottom right
Caption: corner and up the top left we have an
Caption: ingestion api and so that ingestion api
Caption: is constantly receiving screenshot data
Caption: from laptops
Caption: and it does two things it first of all
Caption: it stores the actual image data in redis
Caption: which is the screenshot cache there and
Caption: then it publishes an event so anyone
Caption: that wants to know about that screenshot
Caption: can be informed about it and really the
Caption: only
Caption: subscriber of that event is the
Caption: teacher's browser um so
Caption: hey littlejohny's you know watching
Caption: youtube a new event arrives the
Caption: teacher's browser makes a request to the
Caption: api to the data service and to redis to
Caption: fetch the fresh image
Caption: now
Caption: when we first went live or sorry when we
Caption: first experienced the growth
Caption: our event service got destroyed and i'm
Caption: not actually going to talk about that
Caption: but we and so as you can see here we had
Caption: 1500 events going in and only 150 coming
Caption: out the other side and this was actually
Caption: a terrible terrible experience for our
Caption: teachers
Caption: they couldn't effectively
Caption: conduct remote learning sessions
Caption: so we replaced the event service but
Caption: then something else happened kaboom
Caption: redis caught on fire
Caption: and and i've seen this many times
Caption: actually you remove one bottleneck to
Caption: discover another
Caption: so what did we do
Caption: so the good news is we had thought a
Caption: little bit about this and we're like ah
Caption: there's gonna be more events hitting the
Caption: teachers browsers so why don't we just
Caption: queue them up send and then create a
Caption: batch request and send that off to the
Caption: api so we can load multiple screenshots
Caption: in one go
Caption: we did that
Caption: um but then redis caught fire and so
Caption: first of all
Caption: personally i screamed at the impossible
Caption: because i've used redis a lot and i've
Caption: never destroyed it before so
Caption: this is the first for me
Caption: um
Caption: now we had to resolve the customer
Caption: customer issue immediately because it
Caption: was effectively a complete outage to
Caption: people using the classroom product so we
Caption: actually added in a dynamic throttle to
Caption: our
Caption: event service which is just handcrafted
Caption: code that basically just dropped a
Caption: percentage of screenshots and so we
Caption: could turn it up or turn it down
Caption: at runtime and and and so we would
Caption: follow the production load and um when
Caption: it got too much turn it down a little
Caption: bit turn it down a little bit uh and
Caption: that was really good but also very sad
Caption: as a developer you never really want to
Caption: live at the capabilities of your service
Caption: and obviously we can commenced
Caption: investigation
Caption: so what did we observe
Caption: uh one minor observation was that our
Caption: data service was a bit slow and needed
Caption: replacing but that data service was
Caption: horizontally scalable so whilst it
Caption: wasn't wonderful we could spend a bit
Caption: more and still be online
Caption: and we were just using redis as a
Caption: vanilla key value cache
Caption: and for those that don't know redis is
Caption: actually single threaded much like node
Caption: and so you know there's no contention
Caption: there it's just a single thread that
Caption: does all the work
Caption: uh and we noticed that the redis cpu was
Caption: actually at 100
Caption: so something's definitely going on
Caption: going on here
Caption: now fortunately for us we we had a
Caption: dashboard and we we had the redis
Caption: commands on our dash so we knew
Caption: which commands were being used and we
Caption: there were only four
Caption: put get
Caption: multiple get and keys
Caption: now
Caption: multiple get was interesting so this is
Caption: when the teacher's browser calls back
Caption: with a collection of students and says
Caption: get me the
Caption: screenshots for all these students
Caption: but in this case um you know there might
Caption: be just 10 students at absolute worst
Caption: and and five keys so that's 50 50. so
Caption: that's not super expensive but then
Caption: keys in itself though this is the number
Caption: of items in the redis cache the number
Caption: of screenshots that we have in there and
Caption: so there's a hundred thousand of those
Caption: probably and so that that that is
Caption: dubious why are we calling keys so we
Caption: we weren't the authors of the data
Caption: service so we dug a little deeper
Caption: so it turns out that a single user can
Caption: have multiple windows and so
Caption: that could be another monitor or maybe
Caption: they've got separate chrome windows
Caption: but each of those ends up we get a
Caption: different screenshot for each of those
Caption: and so we used user id plus
Caption: window id as our cache key in redis and
Caption: so if we looked at the data service we
Caption: would see some pseudo code that says
Caption: hey redis get me all all keys that match
Caption: this user id
Caption: and then now then i've got my set of
Caption: user ids hey redis can you please get me
Caption: all the screenshots for these users
Caption: so
Caption: the first one is horrible because we you
Caption: know we may have to redis may need to
Caption: iterate through a thousand sorry 100 000
Caption: cash keys
Caption: and then the second ones we can deal
Caption: with that's absolutely fine
Caption: so we know we need to eliminate keys but
Caption: how are we going to do it
Caption: so we were using redis as a key valve
Caption: but fortunately redis also supports hash
Caption: tables as the value
Caption: and so what we can actually do now is
Caption: say our key is just the student or the
Caption: user id and our hash table
Caption: the key within the hash table is the
Caption: window id and then the value is the the
Caption: image data
Caption: so what what effect did this have
Caption: well redis was a lot happier
Caption: um and so we can see that we've
Caption: we've got two two network calls have
Caption: become one which is a win
Caption: um and similarly the the actual redis
Caption: operation h get all um or hashgraph
Caption: uh there's very few keys that we're
Caption: actually examining with that so it's
Caption: effectively constant time lookup for us
Caption: so
Caption: we
Caption: we went live with this change um and
Caption: all of a sudden um we were started
Caption: receiving feedback from support that our
Caption: customers are happy again and everything
Caption: was resolved so it's a big win for us
Caption: and our support staff and also the sales
Caption: team
Caption: but
Caption: we we had observed that redis was still
Caption: operating at about 70 cpu so we're
Caption: putting it under
Caption: pretty high load so we had some further
Caption: work to do but
Caption: fortunately we could spend our time here
Caption: and actually do a little bit of research
Caption: and plan out how we wanted to attack
Caption: things
Caption: so
Caption: we replaced standalone redis with
Caption: clustered redis
Caption: we actually replaced the data service
Caption: with the screenshot service which was
Caption: much more performant
Caption: and then all the way through we
Caption: effectively used streaming so
Caption: in the case of redis we use res
Caption: pipelining for streaming but then that
Caption: from in the case of anything that was
Caption: http
Caption: we used chunked encoding
Caption: and that enabled us to keep
Caption: memory under control and not actually
Caption: have to allocate or bring the entire
Caption: classroom full of screenshots into
Caption: memory for our api
Caption: so
Caption: our job's not done though just because
Caption: our customers are happy it doesn't mean
Caption: we have things to do so we need to have
Caption: a retrospective
Caption: so what went wrong here well
Caption: first of all i personally made the
Caption: mistake of not doing proper analysis
Caption: and load testing of the screenshots api
Caption: and and the reason for that is in part
Caption: because i
Caption: you know i'd never broken redis before i
Caption: didn't think it was breakable
Caption: um
Caption: another observation was that good
Caption: observability really did enable us to
Caption: resolve this problem quickly for our
Caption: customers um and that in turn gave great
Caption: confidence to our support and sales
Caption: teams
Caption: the other one was that a root cause fix
Caption: here
Caption: we knew that this problem was done and
Caption: dusted with and it wasn't going to come
Caption: back to bite us we might have future
Caption: problems but we were satisfied that this
Caption: this same issue wasn't going to recur
Caption: another another observation was that
Caption: redis has excellent documentation every
Caption: single redis command
Caption: they provide us the big o notation so as
Caption: software engineers we know how our code
Caption: is going to perform when we interact
Caption: with redis assuming we've read the
Caption: manual
Caption: but
Caption: and then finally um simplicity again
Caption: going back to this um the kiss
Caption: the kiss sorry keep it simple stupid um
Caption: the data service was really easy to
Caption: replace with the screenshot service and
Caption: so again i felt that
Caption: in my like
Caption: whenever we do future software
Caption: development work just again try and keep
Caption: everything really simple
Caption: okay so
Caption: covering all of these issues
Caption: how can we apply the performance
Caption: principles to our day-to-day returns
Caption: so the first thing for me is
Caption: documentation i know documentation in
Caption: some ways is a little bit of a dry
Caption: subject
Caption: but um
Caption: i think we should document service level
Caption: objectives so a service level objective
Caption: is really a contract between you and
Caption: your customer so and that might be from
Caption: what a service being the customer of
Caption: another service or or a human customer
Caption: using interacting with your website
Caption: and so
Caption: work with your user user experience team
Caption: or your
Caption: product management team and define what
Caption: your slos are so do you expect all of
Caption: your pages to be fully rendered within
Caption: two seconds
Caption: maybe you probably should in that case
Caption: make sure that that's widely known and
Caption: documented similarly with new features
Caption: make sure that we
Caption: write slos into the acceptance criteria
Caption: and you know different
Caption: different features for example will have
Caption: different slos so if you've got a search
Caption: api you're going to want that thing to
Caption: be pretty quickly users are going to
Caption: expect to see results quickly so make it
Caption: quick
Caption: but then something like a reporting job
Caption: it's absolutely fine to take your time
Caption: right what else can we document
Caption: database index usage
Caption: so it's a really simple one but if
Caption: you've got code that interacts with a db
Caption: um document the index i i firmly believe
Caption: this helps with long-term maintenance
Caption: plus it's a really good educational
Caption: piece so
Caption: um newer developers kind of less
Caption: experienced developers coming into a
Caption: team will see this and then they'll be
Caption: curious and ask questions or look at
Caption: documentation so
Caption: it's very very useful
Caption: okay now here's a here's another example
Caption: we're going to if you as a software
Caption: engineer have thought about
Caption: the performance implications of your
Caption: code and there's something that you
Caption: should point out to future readers
Caption: document it
Caption: so
Caption: this method here is a very simple method
Caption: that looks through a collection of
Caption: intervals and and determines whether any
Caption: of those
Caption: intervals contains
Caption: the current time
Caption: that could be the future time as well
Caption: actually it's poorly named variable
Caption: um
Caption: so how could we document this
Caption: so
Caption: in our case we might be using this to
Caption: determine whether or not a teacher has a
Caption: class that's active right now
Caption: but we know that a teacher is never
Caption: going to have more than 100 classes and
Caption: and so we're super happy
Caption: iterating through 100 items because that
Caption: will never we we're confident this will
Caption: never become a performance
Caption: performance pain for us and and so we
Caption: know that it runs in constant time but
Caption: hey if we used an interval tree then we
Caption: could get log in which would be much
Caption: much faster but
Caption: interval trees aren't in the jdk
Caption: and and we we're never going to use this
Caption: with more than 100 intervals so it
Caption: doesn't matter
Caption: but we can go better still
Caption: i i know a few of you a few people in
Caption: the audience won't be liking this one
Caption: but we we should be logging this as an
Caption: error because this method was designed
Caption: only to support 100 intervals
Caption: uh and hopefully we have monitoring on
Caption: our monitoring and alerting on errors in
Caption: our logs so
Caption: if we get pinged about this whilst we
Caption: might not have a customer issue we can
Caption: prevent a customer issue from occurring
Caption: well similarly this could actually we
Caption: may have 100 intervals because we've got
Caption: bad data in our db something else has
Caption: changed and all of a sudden we've got
Caption: more data than we need to so so these
Caption: kinds of statements can be very very
Caption: useful
Caption: right observability
Caption: super super useful
Caption: now
Caption: what the what that really means is that
Caption: us as software engineers we're looking
Caption: at logs and metrics and traces
Caption: we should be able to have a reasonable
Caption: idea or indication of what's going on
Caption: with our software and systems
Caption: that may not always be true but most of
Caption: the time we should be able to
Caption: why would we want to do this
Caption: well if we've got things to look at
Caption: we can look at them frequently and and
Caption: that enables us to become familiar so we
Caption: know what what usage patterns service a
Caption: has and at what times of the day
Caption: and if we're looking at it frequently we
Caption: know what it looks like normally and if
Caption: we notice anything different then we can
Caption: dig into that proactively
Caption: similarly if we if we do have an outage
Caption: um and actually whether or not it's
Caption: related to performance we can improve
Caption: our mean time to resolve by having
Caption: excellent observability
Caption: and the final point here is just that in
Caption: this day and age a lot of our systems
Caption: are quite complex so we might be talking
Caption: to readers we might talk to a database
Caption: we might be using
Caption: pub sub there's
Caption: lots of things all
Caption: co-mingled and maybe we're orchestrating
Caption: with kubernetes
Caption: in this complex system there are many
Caption: unknowns we don't know how our system is
Caption: going to fail
Caption: but if we've got good observability when
Caption: unknowns do
Caption: come up we can normally convert them to
Caption: knowns fairly effectively
Caption: so what do we need
Caption: and sadly there is no no perfect answer
Caption: here
Caption: it really depends on what the thing is
Caption: are you trying to observe a web page or
Caption: a mobile app or you're trying to observe
Caption: something that's server-side
Caption: um
Caption: yeah all of these things have different
Caption: requirements and how is that thing being
Caption: used
Caption: um you know is it is it critical uh what
Caption: happened what does it mean for your
Caption: customer if you have an outage and then
Caption: finally what's your budget because some
Caption: of the tools are expensive
Caption: so yeah so as mentioned there's many
Caption: kinds of things that we could also
Caption: measure and monitor i won't go into
Caption: those
Caption: now this observability triangle really
Caption: goes from the
Caption: top which is the best of the
Caption: observability but it's also the most
Caption: expensive either through dollars or um
Caption: where dollars may be just cash or or
Caption: dollars could be time
Caption: so apm stands for application
Caption: performance monitor and this gives us
Caption: wonderful insight into our
Caption: existing
Caption: services and
Caption: uh next down the list we've got
Caption: boundaries and dump sorry boundaries
Caption: which basically just means whenever your
Caption: application speaks to something else or
Caption: you cross a tier within the application
Caption: that that's a boundary and so you should
Caption: you should measure around that to
Caption: understand
Caption: what happens when you cross that
Caption: boundary
Caption: similarly it's critical to be able to
Caption: heap and stack them for this they're
Caption: very useful and there's different ways
Caption: you can do that but
Caption: definitely worth doing and then the
Caption: simplest and cheapest of all is just
Caption: making sure you've got rudimentary
Caption: metrics uh and monitoring over critical
Caption: paths and endpoints
Caption: and i'll just jump on to what an apm
Caption: actually looks like because not everyone
Caption: may have seen them before i stole this
Caption: image from datadog's website and and i
Caption: should also say that whilst we are a
Caption: datadog customer we don't use datadog
Caption: apms because they're expensive
Caption: so
Caption: all of a sudden we can see inside a
Caption: particular service and we can see
Caption: where we're spending a lot of time like
Caption: which method we're spending a lot of
Caption: time in and us as us as developers we we
Caption: know whether or not this is an issue i
Caption: might be expecting to sleep not asleep a
Caption: lot so so that's okay but
Caption: it just gives us so much insight into
Caption: our running application
Caption: now
Caption: this is an example of where in a
Caption: previous life
Caption: new relic
Caption: has an apm as well and new relic saved
Caption: us
Caption: so
Caption: we had some code that this i worked for
Caption: an e-commerce company and our service
Caption: was responsible for showing prices on
Caption: all
Caption: websites and all mobile apps and we had
Caption: many millions of active users
Caption: um
Caption: and what had happened is there's an api
Caption: layer managed by another team that's
Caption: that was above our service and that was
Caption: moving from a caching to a non-caching
Caption: architecture so our service
Caption: used to get about 250 250 requests per
Caption: second but then
Caption: over a period of a few months got up to
Caption: about
Caption: 25 000 per second
Caption: and so
Caption: anyway we we noticed that we'd started
Caption: to slow down and our metrics had blown
Caption: out and we got alerted and so we jumped
Caption: into new relic and had a look
Caption: and
Caption: the bit of code that it pointed to i
Caption: looked at this load deal
Caption: yep i know it's going to be the
Caption: talking to the db it's always the db
Caption: it's going to be fined by id
Caption: wrong it was not
Caption: our db was fine our connection pooling
Caption: was fine
Caption: instead we were using java 6 at the time
Caption: and the currency class within
Caption: java 6 is actually pretty inefficient
Caption: and the the get instance method
Caption: actually takes out a synchronize a
Caption: global synchronized lock
Caption: and so only one thread can execute that
Caption: now fortunately it is using a hash map
Caption: so it does run in constant time but
Caption: still there is so much contention on
Caption: that lock amongst other threads that
Caption: this was a major bottleneck and um
Caption: new relic pointed us exactly to where
Caption: that bottleneck was and we were able to
Caption: resolve that
Caption: in under an hour actually and get the
Caption: prod fix out and so that's excellent you
Caption: know mean time to recovery
Caption: now
Caption: we are coders
Caption: and hopefully we all do code review as
Caption: well maybe we pay a program
Caption: and so really these practices apply
Caption: equally to both
Caption: i think the first and most important one
Caption: or at least depends on what you're doing
Caption: but
Caption: always consider growth and scale like
Caption: um
Caption: what what's our
Caption: sales forecast like how many new
Caption: customers are we going to have in the
Caption: future
Caption: what if we have 10 000 things instead of
Caption: 10
Caption: is there any unnecessary io or
Caption: connection
Caption: uh
Caption: if i'm talking if i'm writing code that
Caption: interacts with the database if i'm using
Caption: hibernate or another orm well then make
Caption: sure i'm logging sql and run query plans
Caption: against the output sql
Caption: there's a lot that we can do
Caption: all right so this example um
Caption: was fairly recently
Caption: uh at family zone we introduced a new
Caption: database technology something called
Caption: cockroachdb which is a horizontally
Caption: scalable relational db it's very cool
Caption: tech but we've never used it before
Caption: and so we had a really simple
Caption: simple relationship here it's a
Caption: many-to-many relationship between
Caption: users and guardians
Caption: and and
Caption: so the fortunately the
Caption: software engineers in the team
Caption: they they decided to run some load up
Caption: this database before we got anywhere
Caption: near production with data and then run
Caption: some query plans and they quickly saw
Caption: that what they thought would be a really
Caption: quick query actually scanned 28 000 rows
Caption: and so this was strange they've just got
Caption: a very simple many-to-many relationship
Caption: they've defined their foreign keys what
Caption: was going on
Caption: so as it turned out um different
Caption: databases have different characteristics
Caption: and uh one of cockroaches
Caption: characteristics is that when you create
Caption: a foreign key it doesn't automatically
Caption: create an index on the column referenced
Caption: in the foreign table
Caption: not all dbs do but they hadn't
Caption: experienced it before
Caption: but
Caption: fortunately for them they did their due
Caption: diligence as
Caption: and ran query plans and they added the
Caption: index and got their estimated row count
Caption: down to one and the thing i like about
Caption: this is it was spending time with the
Caption: new technology reading the manual
Caption: working through it um and
Caption: this would definitely have become a
Caption: production issue if they hadn't done
Caption: this because we were going to load this
Caption: up with
Caption: about 3 million students so and it was
Caption: going to be hit a lot
Caption: so that's it for me thank you very much
Caption: for listening
Caption: just to kind of recap we
Caption: i introduced a few principles and
Caption: explained how i think though they help
Caption: us to derive good practices as software
Caption: engineers
Caption: hopefully some of this was useful useful
Caption: to you thank you very much